not every city in america is like that
why san francisco like that
you know and by the way i don't know if
you guys hurt or not one of the salons
was open this week
one of the salons oh is that right and
one of your good friends nancy pelosi
went to the salon
she called me for she called me for the
hookup i got her in hey
kai can we see this video of nancy
pelosi going to the salon i mean
honestly
we got to see this video kai's been
upping his game with
videos lately look at that
that's nancy pelosi watch your step good
boom good for her she didn't rock in the
high school
how irresponsible to not put a mask on
at her age
you know what my first impression of
this is okay we all know politicians
take shortcuts they expect preferential
treatment that doesn't shock me
she's doing that the mask thing bothers
me more because
in california they'll give you a fine if
you don't have one on i mean they're
constantly in your face that you like
you walk across the street they have
mass police in some cities you know if
you don't have it on they're harassing
you
the fact she's getting her hair done
doesn't shock me but not
wearing a mask is a slap in the face to
everybody that's how to change their
lifestyle and wear one
all the time it's ridiculous now that
the challenge is so
she the owner of the salon decides to
kai if you can move it up a little bit
so we can see the picture the the owner
of the salon decides to release this
video
so they asked her why'd you release the
video she said i thought it was fair
because
other salon owners have been shut down
and they asked me to open up mine and
it's a community and i would also be
protective of them
so i open it up what do you think about
her opening up the salon for pelosi and
then
sharing this video with the public so
i'll give you
you know two sides of the coin here
right so obviously
the optics of this are horrible i mean
this is hypocrisy at its finest breaking
news everybody
politicians uh don't always uh do as
they say do as they do right i mean
they'll tell you one thing and then do
what they want to do right so
that's that's nancy thing however you
could take the other side of the coin
which i'm sure nancy's saying is
you set me up bro you set me up i called
you up
you know it's gonna clear the space just
for me no one else in there
there's nobody else in there except for
me and my hairdresser and then you rat
on me
so i i do am i a fan of what she's doing
am i an advocate of
of nancy and her hypocrisy not at all
however i'm sure she's basically saying
she was set up is that what her defense
is set up
getting that's not a setup okay that
that it's being exposed
the mistake the salon owner made is not
calling tmz and making money off it
hopefully that salon owner made money
off this video right because her shop
has been closed
for five months so hopefully that she
was able to capitalize on it and then
did you happen to see that the next day
that they start
lifting some of the limitations in
california yeah that's saying that now
you can open barber shops
and salons with limited people inside
amazing timing isn't isn't governor
newsome pelosi's nephew
i don't know if they're actually related
check to see if there's uh
their relatives because i saw somewhere
that news newsom
uh related right they're related to
pelosi there you go click on that
uh gavin newsom uh related to pelosi
he is the brother-in-law of nancy pelosi
the speaker doesn't remember
the in-laws former uncle buddy let's
talk about ron pelosi
no i'm okay so then that would be
so it looks like maybe her husband
somehow was related okay
interesting there's some kind of kai
click go back to that guy and just click
people also ask just scroll down how is
governor know some related go
the top one kai top one boom
click on that while in school newsom
spent the semester studying abroad in
rome newsome's aunt was married to ron
pelosi the brother-in-law speaker of
the united states of house
representatives there's some
relationships it is
when you think of gavin newsom his
ex-wife is completely guilt i mean it's
unbelievable
you know here's the other thing i love
about this story is yet to come
whoa the fact that nancy pelosi is 80.
that's what i learned from this story as
well she's 80 80 years old forget term
limits there should be age limits on
congress people
there really should
age discrimination and then you've seen
the scenarios right if they can't
pick the winner of the election that she
could somehow become the president as
speaker of the house 80 years old
[Music]
unbelievable